finland's prime minister sana marin has
defended her right to a private life
after a video of her partying with
friends was leaked online the video
showing martin with well-known
influencers and artists has brought
accusations of reckless behavior martin
says she did nothing illegal and has
taken a drug test to prove it
an innocent night out with friends or
dereliction of public duty
finland's prime minister sana marine is
at pains to prove it was the former
after this video showing her partying
and speculation about drug taking went
viral opposition parties demanded proof
she'd not consumed an illegal substance
[Music]
i consider these accusations very
serious
and though i think the demand for a drug
test is unreasonable
for my own legal protection and to clear
up doubts i've taken a test today
the results will come in about a week
marine's behavior has divided the
finnish public
some have defended her right to enjoy
her free time as she pleases like anyone
else others have called her behavior
inappropriate and say she was naive to
allow the filming she was on duty as pm
at the time but says she had no imminent
appointments i didn't have
any
work meetings planned for that weekend
they are confirmed usually
beforehand and i didn't have any
meetings for example saturday or sunday
but we didn't have any government
meetings during that week and i had
time off and and spent it with my
friends and did nothing illegal
still her critics question whether she
could have made decisions in a sudden
crisis in her condition
marine has the support of her social
democratic party and intelligence
experts say the incident did not risk
national security but they warn it could
be exploited for propaganda purposes for
example by russia
you have to be prepared for the fact
that all material that starts
circulating can be used in the wrong way
became the world's youngest serving
government leader in 2019 aged just 34.
she has since been criticized for
letting her hair down at parties at her
official residence and last december she
apologized after it was revealed she'd
gone out clubbing till 4am after being
exposed to covid19
well our correspondent terry schultz in
brussels is following the story for us
terry the opposition says the problem is
not that she was having fun with friends
but that she was on duty does this kind
of behavior actually create a security
risk for the country
well nicole they've actually come out
intelligence officials and said there
was no security risk from santa maria's
behavior and we should point out that
there's no evidence that she did
anything wrong dancing is not illegal in
finland
drinking alcohol as an adult is not
illegal and she does not appear even in
that video and i've watched it many
times
to seem incapacitated in any way but the
truth is that in a country like finland
which shares a border of 1 340
kilometers with russia national security
questions are taken very seriously and
are discussed quite transparently in
public and that's what this is really
coming down to and in the end it's it's
not so much whether she would have
needed to take a decision at that moment
that she was dancing in front of her
friend's camera but whether the video
itself can be used for propaganda and as
you heard expert hannah smith say there
are already signs that russia is trying
to exploit this video
this was of course meant to be a private
video though do we know how it was
leaked
we don't know and i've just checked with
finnish friends again in the last few
minutes to make sure that we haven't
seen
any evidence about who leaked it and
this in fact might be a bigger security
question nicole because of course uh
sanamaran and and everyone there will
know who was behind the phone but if
that person and i would expect that
someone in that close circle would not
purposely put it out perhaps there is a
lack of security uh in their phone
system uh in in uh in the you know the
people in networks close to santa maria
and that might be something that really
is worth more of more scrutiny when it
when it comes to security if these
phones can be hacked so easily that this
video could be put out and i would
expect that people are looking at that
very closely now
this entire thing has triggered a heated
debate about
whether a video like this would have
caused the same stir if the prime
minister were an older man is marin
under particular scrutiny in finland for
being young and for being a woman
i think she is and i lived in finland
for eight years and i've i study the
country quite carefully you know finland
has had
a lot of leaders who've done things that
might not be considered so
publicly proper they were drinkers they
had mistresses they had quite close
relationships with soviet leaders and
you don't hear so much about that of
course there wasn't twitter there
weren't social social
mobile videos that could be uh
disseminated into the public and so they
got away with a lot more so now you have
this extroverted
beautiful young woman seeming to have
fun while on the job and there's
something about finland that says you
know perhaps that's just a bit much they
they aren't so lighthearted at times and
i think they might be a little bit
uncomfortable with it but of course you
have seen young people also cheering her
on and saying have a good time when
you're off duty madame prime minister
thank you very much dw correspondent
terry schultz from brussels
you